voilà
alors samantha fox 95 c'est chanter
valérie lemercier mais à l'époque où
vous posiez pour la page 3 les tabloïds
anglais notamment le sun c'était 95d il
va voir beaucoup plus gros
dans le sol il disait que je faisais à
36 double des 15 w mais j'ai toujours
cherché le deuxième des j'ai jamais
trouvé comme il a expliqué que
l'agresseur n'a pas d'importance ya que
les boues qui font du bien
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas celui qui à la batte la puce
qui
sera relayé le plus extraordinaire avec
vous somme c'est quand vous étiez enfant
vous étiez plate comme une limande et
votre oncle charlie se moquer de vos
seins il disait que ça ressemblait des
piqûres de guêpes c'est vrai
ou deux oeufs au plat
j'ai une puberté très tardive et j'avais
en gros 15 ans et demi et pourquoi mes
amis avait des poils sous les bras des
poils pubiens où je n'avais rien à elle
était plate voilà des lunettes à la non
un appareil dentaire
valette moi c'est vrai je vous montre
les photos et alors quand vous avez 15
ans ils sont mis à pousser terriblement
à cause de quoi en deux heures
au buzzer
je ne vous écoute pas vous
même à la fm c'était un moment dans ma
vie j'avais 15 ans et je croyais au
collège et j'ai commencé à faire mes
révisions je ne plaisante pas et tout
d'un coup du jour au lendemain je suis
devenue une femme
incroyable tenir deux heures bon ya pas
une clé ça on va arrêter avec l'esat
aussi
bon à 16h 20m et sam fox mesdames
messieurs je sais comment on fait alors
en bon produit comment
vous est parfaite
[Applaudissements]
non il faut voir la gentillesse de
mettre un verre d'eau devant sam fox
parce qu'on va lui parler de son père la
dernière fois qu'on a parlé de son père
à quelqu'un ici c'était milla jovovich
et que ça s'est très très mal terminée à
la jetée le vert
donc je vais vous parler de votre père
et si vraiment ça vous ennuie elle vous
jetez le vert
[Applaudissements]
donc si vous êtes énervé yosa vous
poussez le vert comme ça dorothée voile
alors votre père travailler dans la
construction avant de devenir votre
manager et votre mère était danseuse
jusqu'à ce qu'elle s'occupe de votre fan
club vos parents vous ont donné une
bonne éducation catholique très strictes
n'était pas mes parents
c'est moi même en fait et à l'époque
j'habitais dans east end de londres car
il est très difficile et la meilleure
éducation je pouvais avoir c'était dans
une école catholique
donc je suis allé dans cette école et
lorsque j'ai quitté l'école mon père est
devenu mon manager parce que j'étais
assis chaîne alors vos parents n'ont pas
vu d'un mauvais oeil finalement que vous
embrassiez la la carrière de chanteuse
et de pin up mais quand vous avez décidé
de devenir une fille de la page 3 du sun
vos parents ne s'y sont pas opposés
d'une certaine façon
sa sextape parce que j'avais 16 ans et
j'avais envie de faire je pouvais me
décider c'était très mûrs pour moi l'âge
est jeune on était obligé de faire face
à des hommes comme lui en gros afin qu'à
l'âge de 14 ans donc j'ai appris à
jamais ce que je veux dire j'ai été
obligé de faire face aux hommes et à
lévis alors votre père est devenu votre
manager il a il a gagné pas mal d'argent
avec vous et dès qu'il a eu suffisamment
d'argent il a quitté votre mère pour une
fille plus jeune
était marié à mon père pendant 25 ans et
elle était une malheureuse a été
malheureuse pour les cinq dernières
années mais ma maman était une maman
typique et
sous ce qu'elle gagnait ça allait pour
la famille pour la maison et chaque fois
qu'elle disait à mon père je veux te
quitter
il lui disait tu n'as rien et c'est
quand j'ai commencé à gagner de l'argent
que j'ai pu aider ma mère qu'elle a pu
quitter mon père et être heureuse un et
alors après vous avez accusé votre père
de vous avoir pris de l'argent d'avoir
détourné des sommes d'argent que vous
avez gagné non je ne vais pas accuser
c'est le service des impôts qui m'ont
informé
un jour
on a annoncé que j'étais la cinquième
femme la plus riche d'angleterre et les
impôts ont commencé une enquête j'étais
jeudi mais papa ou et tout l'argent il
médite inquiète pas on s'en occupe
et tout d'un coup j'ai eu une grosse
grosse facture
et il a fallu que je vende de maison
et que je vende tous que
j'avais gagné j'avais acheté avec ce que
j'avais gagné depuis l'âge de 16 ans
donc ça a été une période difficile mais
ça a été bon en même temps parce que ça
m'a rendu forte et ça m'a fait mûrir ça
m'a fait réaliser aussi ce que c'est que
l'argent alors pourquoi vous êtes
discuter avec votre père alors
parce qu'il a pris tout ce que j'avais
et vous avez essayé un moment de vous
arranger avec lui deux pour pas aller
jusqu'au procès
j'ai essayé et j'ai découvert qu'il
vendait l'histoire de ma vie à une
société de polisseur film et j'ai fait
mon éducation que je voulais me
rencontrer à couper tout allait bien et
que le film ce cas même bien mais je ne
suis pas bête à ce point là je me suis
rendu compte qu'à nouveau c'était encore
une histoire de faire
parfois pour la gloire les gens disaient
ce que la gloire vous a changé l'eau ce
sont les gens autour de moi qui ont été
changés par
depuis mon père
connaît maintenant les gens autour de
moi à l'affiché fait confiance ils
forment un gros show comme ça dans la
vie parfois
pour se comprendre soi-même et savoir
qui sont vos amis et à qui faire
confiance malheureusement c'était mon
père mais voilà ça a été la période la
plus dure de votre vie
alors quand votre père est mort en
septembre 2000 à l'âge de 56 ans vous
n'aviez pas parlé avec lui depuis des
années et vous avez déclaré si j'avais
su qu'il avait si mal j'aurais essayé de
le revoir avant de surmonter nos
différents
oui
je ne savais pas où il était pendant
quatre ans après ça
on fait ma soeur m'a appelé le jouet des
morts
vous n'avez jamais revu les dents mais
ça a été un gros choc
et j'ai écrit une belle lettre je lui ai
dit que je l'aimais y que je te jure le
pardonner
et on est tous les enfants de dieu au
bout du compte
je crois que ma paire a été pris par le
showbiz la gloire l'alcool et la drogue
et lorsque ces choses arrivent aux gens
l'état de la teste et je crois france la
gelée vu ça fait 20 ans que je suis dans
la série ce business je les ai vus non
seulement avec son père mais avec des
amis d'autres rapstar et l'alcool et la
drogue c'est un jeu dangereux
[Musique]
jamais
oui
alors ça vous êtes très populaire en
france les français vous aime beaucoup
depuis de longues années on va voir si
vous êtes en phase avec l'opinion
publique française
interview opinion publique
[Applaudissements]
38% des femmes préfèrent faire l'amour
au réveil et vous
oui
je rêvais toujours avec un sourire et
c'est toujours dont 56% des femmes
préfèrent faire l'amour dans le noir et
vous
oh non
non je viens pour la sa lumière
34% des femmes sont d'accord pour faire
l'amour où il veut quand il veut et vous
soyez un compromis
le sec ça se discute entre nous deux
personnes
ont envie de faire
ça
et là
vous le faites tout ça oui avec des
photos de tout
sam 33% des femmes demandent à leurs
partenaires ce qu'elles veulent qu'il
leur fasse et vous
la communication dans la chambre à
coucher très important si vous avez
quelque chose il faut le dire on peut
pas imaginer que chaque homme c est ce
que vous voulez et déjà si un homme aime
quelque chose eh bien il faut qu'il me
dise
si moi j'aime d'accord quelque chose je
lui dis quand 9% des femmes refusent de
se faire attacher vous
bon ce soir
66% des femmes sont choqués par le
sadomasochisme et vous à like
j'aime bien la nourriture pas la
punition quand 9% des femmes refusent la
fellation et vous
j'adore la glace
65% des femmes c'est beaucoup en france
1 refuse la relation à trois et vous
je ne dis jamais jamais
alors après l'amour en france 36% des
femmes se lavent
29% dorment 8% fume 7% bois vous mange 5
% regarde la télé et 6% recommence vous
êtes dans quelle catégorie
je recommence
pour être sûr de moitié raté lienhard dj
art design et vous abonnez vous mettez
un pouce levé un pouce bleus